présidente c'est l'office a déjà eu à
traiter de telles affaires par le passé
ce n'est pas du tout le cas
toutefois il est bien évidemment arriver
que certaines victimes prostituées dans
les affaires de traiter de proxénétisme
que nous avons en portefeuille est été
par le passé actrice dans le domaine de
la pornographie
nous ne nous étions pas concertés madame
moir ont brouillé mois avant cette
intervention mais je pense qu'on est à
peu près tout à fait sur la même ligne
la porosité entre le monde de la
prostitution est celui de la
pornographie est évidente
vous l'avez largement d'ailleurs évoqué
dans les travaux de votre table ronde
dont j'ai pris connaissance
j'ajouterai simplement que mes
enquêteurs dans leur travail quotidien
sur internet pour démanteler des réseaux
de proxénétisme
tombe très régulièrement sur des
annonces vantant l'expérience dans le
domaine de la pornographie des
prostituées
il ya un acronyme bien connu une maison
quêteurs qui s'appelle pse 1 point
d'orgue expérience donc ça veut tout
dire
[Musique]